Let's talk about college and politics and
economics because I did a story a couple of
weeks ago about the future of the United States
in the context of so many of our systems seeming
completely unsustainable.
And when I did that story a couple of weeks
ago, we talked about inequality.
We talked about the healthcare system which
causes countless medical bankruptcies every
year and we also talked about education where
we were seeing and we continue to see the
cost of college rising dramatically.
Wages are relatively stagnant and this makes
college both less affordable and also less
of a good investment relative to the wages
that one would expect and that's what I want
to dig into today.
I want to ask you, might we be getting to
the end of the college era as we may end up
calling it this era where of course you have
to go to college regardless of the cost to
have a shot in the economy.
I'll explain.
We've already talked about how the exploding
cost of college is far exceeding wage growth
and we are seeing more and more people saddled
with student debt without an ability to ever
pay it off because of the earnings of the
jobs that that college degree ultimately lands
them in.
And if college costs continue going up, it's
a foregone conclusion that fewer and fewer
people will be able to afford it.
And by that I mean to be able to afford paying
off their student loans with the wages they
can expect to earn.
I also said in our segment of last week or
the week before that in the interests of Maine
state, maintaining a profitable status quo
for the establishment and for corporations
and for political elites, every once in a
while a bone can be thrown at people to prevent
them from really protesting to change the
system.
And that this has done to keep the system
just barely sustainable.
Passably sustainable so that the perpetual,
uh, status quo remains.
And interestingly enough, the premium in terms
of net worth for college graduates over non-college
graduates is very quickly shrinking.
Now I want to be clear here because this,
this is, this is important.
There is a huge advantage in terms of income
for those with college degrees over those
without college degrees.
But the advantage in net worth has been shrinking
over time.
And part of the reason is that with stagnant
wages, with people who go to college, having
to pay off the student debt when the money
goes off to pay loans and student loan interest,
rather than building your net worth, it has
a vicious cycle where you earn higher wages
but more of the wages go to paying off student
loans because of the student loans.
You end up having to charge a lot of your
day to day expenses to a credit card, which
means you're paying even more interest, which
further restricts your net worth.
So you make significantly more money with
a college degree.
But the premium in terms of the effect on
your net worth is becoming smaller and smaller.
Now, in addition to this, we've also talked
about the political component to the whole
college space right now, which is that convenient
for the American, right?
They have been to some degree successfully
pushing the idea that college is merely liberal.
Indoctrination colleges restrict conservative
speech and this has been priming a lot of
conservatives to already be skeptical of college.
So we may actually see a movement away from
the requirement of a college degree for more
and more jobs that could reinforce a move
away from people going to college in the first
place.
And in fact there are lots of companies, even
some financial companies where more and more
positions don't require a college degree.
So what's going to happen?
The left has to be careful because if as a
society, we move away from college education
as a requirement for jobs.
If the economy can't support the student debt,
if college makes less sense over time because
of what it costs, that's one thing.
But remember that Republican talking points
work way better on the uneducated.
So if there is indeed a move away from college
education, it could be very, very bad for
the American left.
Since we know that unbalance, the more educated
someone is, the more likely they are to vote
for a more progressive candidate.
So I want to hear from you about this.
Get in touch.
What do you think will eventually happen with
the cost of college?
Are we potentially starting to see a move
away from the college era?
To call it something.
Uh, and what do you predict as the political
future?
If there is this move away from college, let
me know.
Including via voicemail, which is
where
we
are going next.